[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est science public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat de
reportage et d'expertise sur Public
Sénat 90 minutes pour donner du sens à
l'actualité vous proposez des clés de
compréhension des mutations de notre
société voici le sommaire de ceux 10
janvier la réforme des retraites et sur
les rails lors d'une conférence de
presse là première ministre a confirmé
la mesure phare l'âge légal de départ
repoussé à 64 ans en 2030 un totem pour
les syndicats réunis ce soir à la Bourse
du travail dans un mouvement unitaire le
premier depuis 12 ans cette réforme
est-elle indispensable quels sont les
soutiens politiques du gouvernement
qu'elle ampleur la mobilisation
peut-elle prendre réponse dans une
minute et puis pour notre second débat
cette question Paris et l'Île-de-France
ont-elles prêtes à affronter une crue
centenal aussi puissante que celle de
1910 non a répondu la Cour des comptes
dans un rapport il y a deux mois
pourtant un test grandeur nature avait
eu lieu en 2016 le préfet chargé de
l'organiser imaginait l'après inondation
quelle est notre stratégie objective
rétablir rapidement possible l'activité
sur le territoire francilien qu'est-ce
qu'on privilégie par quoi faut-il
commencer quels sont les axes à déblayer
d'abord ou faut-il rétablir l'existence
comment éviter une catastrophe majeure
est-ce encore possible réponse dans 3/4
d'heure mais d'abord un premier extrait
de la conférence de presse d'Elisabeth
borne la réforme des retraites marqueurs
du second quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron
et lancé à compter du premier septembre
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite sera
relevé progressivement de trois mois par
an pour atteindre 64 ans en 2030 nous
serons donc à 63 ans et trois mois à la
fin du quinquennat
parallèlement nous n'irons pas plus loin
que les 43 ans de cotisations prévues
par la réforme Touraine pour partir avec
une retraite à taux plein mais nous
atteindrons cette cible plus vite en
passant à un rythme d'un trimestre par
an nous serons à 43 ans en 2025
enfin nous maintiendrons à 67 ans l'âge
auquel les personnes peuvent partir à la
retraite sans décote quel que soit leur
durée de cotisation
c'est essentiel pour celles et ceux qui
ont eu une carrière hachée ou
incomplètes et je pense ici
particulièrement aux femmes
ce projet est bien universel il
concernera tous les actifs salariés
indépendants et fonctionnaires
notre débat sur cette réforme des
retraites le premier certainement d'une
série qui promet d'être longue au fil
des discussions et de la mobilisation
face à ce projet Catherine tricot
bonsoir vous êtes bienvenue vous êtes
directrice de la revue regarde
j'accueillirique de Lannoy bonsoir
bienvenue à vous aussi économise
président fondateur du cabinet Tensing
et vous avez travaillé sur le programme
économique du candidat Macron lors de
ces deux campagnes présidentielles
notamment sur l'économie sociale et
solidaire
Bertrand Martino bonsoir bienvenue à
vous aussi vous êtes économiste
spécialiste du marché du travail à
l'Institut Montaigne et ancien
conseiller social de Nicolas Sarkozy à
l'Elysée j'accue également Laetitia
cruppa bonsoir Laetitia bienvenue à vous
vous êtes éditorialiste politique
peut-être un premier tour de table tiens
pour savoir comment vous vous situez si
vous êtes favorable ou opposé à cette
réforme Catherine tricot vous y opposé
pourquoi
parce que elle est
inutile c'est-à-dire que on nous fait on
est dans une situation de crise multiple
et qu'on va tendre le pays
qui ont le sait est en désaccord avec
cette réforme alors qu'il y a tant de
projet à affronter tant de consensus à
construire pour faire face à la crise
énergétique et environnemental et il y a
tellement à penser pour recoudre notre
pays que je trouve très malheureux de
commencer ce quinquennat qui devait être
écologique ou ne serait pas par une
réforme qui divise alors qu'il faut
réparer l'hôpital les transports l'école
la justice et on s'attaque à quelque
chose qui est une question qui n'a
aucune caractère d'urgence qui est une
petite question quand par ailleurs on a
tous ces grands enjeux et ces sommes
c'est bénéfices considérables et ces
accumulations de richesse considérable
et approprié par un petit nombre qui ne
sont pas partagés et donc nous aurions
besoin on y reviendra évidemment vous
aurez vous connaissez l'émission le
temps pour développer ces arguments
Eric Delannoy vous y êtes plutôt
favorable on va dire ça comme ça
pourquoi je suis plutôt favorable parce
que alors déjà enfin si c'était une
petite question on ferait pas tant de
bruit donc c'est certainement quand même
plus important qu'on imagine ça pose la
question de l'intergénérationnel ça pose
la question de regarder les effets
structurels de ce qui se passe dans la
société aujourd'hui enfin je veux dire
en 1960 on avait quatre actifs qui
finançaient un retraité aujourd'hui on
est 1,6 actif qui financièrement
retraité en 2050 on sera 1,2 actif qui
finalement pour financer les retraites
donc structurellement on a un
déséquilibre intergénérationnel qui fait
qu'on ne peut pas laisser le système de
retraite dérivé comme il dérive deuxième
élément c'est que j'aime beaucoup la
formule de Bruno Le Maire on ne peut pas
avoir la solidarité à crédit à un moment
le quoi qu'il en coûte il va falloir
s'arrêter et que donc revenir à des
aspects de rigueur budgétaire qui fait
que 10 milliards de déficits qui peuvent
sont transformés en 15 milliards de
déficits par an si on ne fait rien bah
il va falloir trouver des solutions donc
je suis j'y suis favorable parce que au
final ça répond à un besoin structurel
de la société de mon point de vue ça
répond aussi à une manière de regarder
le travail ça répond aussi à un point
qu'on ne cite jamais qui est que nous
sommes le seul pays en Europe qui
n'irait pas sur ce type de réforme à
l'heure où les investisseurs
financent la dette du pays à des coûts
qui sont de plus en plus importants
quand un investisseur se tourne vers un
pays et qu'il voit qu'un pays n'est pas
capable de faire des réformes il ne
finance pas la dette alors on y
reviendra là dessus message envoyé on va
dire aux partenaires européens et aux
investisseurs européens Bertrand
Martineau pour ou contre
mais pour mais le sujet c'est pas les
retraites le sujet c'est l'ensemble des
finances publiques on ne va avoir à
faire face dans les prochaines années
des des charges supplémentaires
considérables sur la santé la défense
nationale le grand âge l'innovation la
recherche la relance du nucléaire donc
finalement vous rejoignez par nos
interrompre
qu'il faut faire mais vous dites il faut
trouver de l'air pour les faire les
quelques dizaines de milliards de de
d'intervention supplémentaire et de
relance supplémentaires qu'il faut faire
je vois pas très bien sur quel poste de
dépenses on peut les faire ailleurs
ailleurs que sur les retraites je vois
mal qu'on baisse de 20 milliards d'euros
puisque c'est à peu près de ça dont on
parle la terre je vois mal qu'on baisse
de 20 milliards les dépenses dans les
hôpitaux je j'imagine tellement le pays
j'imagine pas qu'on baisse de 20
milliards la défense
l'armement que je pense qu'on a des
problèmes considérables de dépenses
supplémentaires dans le grand âge et
donc même sans en appeler à les
comparaisons avec des autres pays chacun
vit sa vie chacun son propre modèle
c'est pas assez même pas le sujet c'est
qu'on a à faire un mur on est devant un
mur de déficit et de finances publiques
et la seule le seul levier vers c'est
pas une position idéologique après il
peut y avoir des effets tout à fait
défavorables sur certaines personnes sur
la retraite et d'un point de vue
macroéconomique disons le seul levier
qu'on a pour dégager quelques milliards
on parle pas de quelques millions
d'euros pour dégager quelques dizaines
de milliards d'euros à l'horizon de
quelques années et bien c'est les
retraites voilà si on me donne un autre
poste de dépenses où on peut faire 20
milliards d'économies ah oui alors les
200 familles peut-être et puis on va
taxer
est un économiste assez reconnu qui a
fait une chronique dans le monde que je
vous recommande il livre ce chiffre il y
a 10 ans les 500 plus grandes familles
françaises non 500 excusez-moi c'était
les 500 mais non mais on peut on peut se
moquer mais se moquer ne fait pas un
argument les 500 plus grandes familles
françaises possédaient 200 milliards 10
ans plus tard elles en possèdent 1000
milliards
c'est à dire qu'elles ont accrues leurs
propriétés privées de 800 milliards
c'est faux ben écoutez vous bon c'est si
c'est pour vous le dire à Piketty et
d'ailleurs nous nous honorons d'avoir en
France l'homme le plus riche du monde
désormais nous avons alors ce que je
veux dire c'est que oui vous le savez
donc si ça veut dire quelque chose ça
veut dire que ça veut dire que des
personnes en France ont accru
considérablement leur richesse et elles
l'ont accrue au bénéfice notamment du
fait qu'elles ont été exonérées de
paiement des impôts notamment je pense à
cet argument sur l'ISF parce que moi je
pense qu'on pourrait remettre l'ISF que
Macron a supprimé une SF qui de ramène
que 5 milliards et précisément s'il
ramène que 5 milliards c'est que c'est
une plaisante alors ce que je dis c'est
que la réforme il y a beaucoup de thèmes
intéressants mais je je vais je voulais
vous entendre là-dessus et je vais
entendre la réponse de de l'un et
l'autre peut-être on peut refaire le
monde mais si oui
mais là on était sur les retraites si
vous voulez mais on peut aussi parler de
taxation on peut
vous savez bien que c'est en augmentant
de deux ans l'âge de départ à la
retraite qu'on va payer tout ce qu'il y
a à payer donc il faut bien refaire le
monde il faut bien refaire le monde et
donc s'interroger sur les inégales de
recherche sur cette question de des
supers riches on va dire ça comme ça on
est sur les éléments de langage
traditionnel de la gauche radicale enfin
sur le thème il suffit il suffit il
suffit il suffit de préfère payer les
riches moi je rappelle que pourquoi
c'est faux et pourquoi je le dis avec
autant de certitudes malgré le respect
que j'ai pour les travaux de Monsieur
Piketty qui fait des travaux forts
intéressants quand il ne fait pas de
politique c'est que c'est qu'en fait ça
ne veut rien dire 200 milliards versus
mille milliards ça veut dire juste une
chose c'est que les entreprises que
possèdent ces gens là ce sont bien
portés parce qu'on a une économie qui
sait très bien portée ça veut dire que
c'est mille milliards là qui ne sont
absolument pas liquides ça s'appelle du
patrimoine liquide d'accord
ça veut dire que c'est des gens qui ont
des actions dans des entreprises et qui
ne les vendent pas comme ça pour générer
leur temps libre pour mettre sur leur
compte en banque donc c'est la valeur de
l'entreprise s'est améliorée donc la
valeur de leurs actions c'est améliorée
donc pardon mais c'est la valeur
d'entreprise donc ce sont les salaires
donc ce sont des ok alors effectivement
ça nous emmène sur un autre débat qui
est passionnant qu'on a déjà eu sur ce
plateau et qu'on aura certainement dans
des dans les dans les prochains mois
parce que c'est aussi la question de la
du partage de la valeur dans une
entreprise par exemple mais on fera ce
débat dans quelques dans quelques jours
je vous le promets je vous donne
d'autres éléments on est en cette fin
d'après-midi en direct sur Public Sénat
annoncé par la première ministre dans
cette conférence de presse donc il y a
assez 64 ans en 2030 ça veut dire trois
mois par an à partir du 1er septembre
allongement de la durée de cotisation
plus rapide on va atteindre 43 ans pour
un taux plein dès 2027 alors que dans la
réforme torrent telle qualité prévue
c'était 2035 extinction des principaux
régimes spéciaux ça c'est un élément
important RATP industrie électricité gaz
ou Banque de France il y a aussi les
éléments sur les carrières longues sur
effectivement ce que budgétaire que ils
avaient borne chiffre elle dit le
déficit sera à 30 milliards de la
sécurité de du régime de retraite pardon
en 2030 d'autres éléments de cette
réforme résumé par Flora sauvage pour
ensuite lancer le débat un peu plus
précisément sur ce qui a annoncé la
première ministre après avoir échoué
lors de son premier quinquennat Emmanuel
Macron remet la réforme des retraites
sur la table cette fois le chef de
l'État a choisi d'écarter le report de
l'âge légal de départ à 65 ans comme il
l'avait promis pendant la campagne
présidentielle la réforme visée
essentiellement à faire des économies
elle est centrée sur une mesure phare le
relèvement de 62 à 64 ans de l'âge de
départ si la réforme est votée par les
députés et les sénateurs il faudra pour
partir à la retraite avoir cotisé 43 ans
et être âgé de 64 ans minimum à partir
de 67 ans un départ restera possible
même sans avoir ses 43 années de
cotisations comme c'est le aujourd'hui
selon un sondage plus de deux tiers des
Français sont opposés au recul de l'âge
de départ à la retraite fait inédit les
syndicats sont tous unis contre la
réforme une journée de grève et de
mobilisation devrait avoir lieu d'ici la
fin janvier
alors l'un des arguments pour eux
justifier cette réforme on l'a déjà un
peu évoqué c'est effectivement la
comparaison européenne je vous propose
tiens la liste des pays on parle plutôt
en Europe la Suède 61 ans la France
jusqu'à présent 62 ans la Grèce 62 ans
la Slovaquie 62 ans et 10 mois et puis
si on va de l'autre côté du curseur
européen on va voir les pays où l'âge
légal est le plus tardif et là on va
trouver l'Italie 67 ans tout comme le
Danemark les Pays-Bas et le Portugal on
est à 66 ans et 7 mois l'Irlande et
l'Espagne à 66 ans l'Allemagne a 65 ans
et 10 mois Catherine tricot en 2027 j'ai
vu ça dans les échos ce matin seul trois
pays de l'Union européenne auront gardé
un âge légal inférieur à 65 ans est-ce
que la France peut être à contre-courant
oui pourquoi parce que il faut il faut
changer le courant
que on va faire une baisse des impôts de
production dès 2023 et qu'on va le payer
c'est la première page de la note c'est
pas du tout un truc secret et qu'on va
le payer grâce à la réforme des
retraites c'est à dire que la logique
actuelle c'est de dire on va continuer
de faire une pression sur le coup du
travail de baisser le coût du travail et
qu'on va le faire en le faisant payer
notamment par les retraites ou et non
seulement en augmentant l'âge de départ
à la retraite mais en faisant baisser le
montant des retraites parce que ce qui
n'est pas dit dans la chanson c'est on
nous raconte l'inverse en vérité le
rapport tous les rapports montre que les
pensions de retraite vont baisser de 20%
dans les 20 prochaines années parce
qu'elles ne sont plus indexées sur
l'augmentation du PIB et sur la richesse
produite mais sur l'inflation c'est à
dire qu'on a une part des retraites les
retraités français bon ça peut ouvrir
c'est toujours au même endroit ce que
vous avez très bien expliqué monsieur
tout à l'heure c'est ton même endroit
qu'on cherche sur les retraités sur les
salariés sur les gens qui triment et en
fait le carreleur qui peut rester à
quatre pattes jusqu'à 64 ans si on
s'imagine que c'est comme ça qu'on va
redresser faire les éoliennes redresser
la France je n'en mets si puisque
nucléaire
et d'énergie renouvelable et éolienne
les investissements que l'on peut faire
ne peuvent pas être fait sur le dos des
salariés et le dos des gens qui
aujourd'hui dit difficilement sans
vouloir être ironique mais si on fait la
réforme des retraites pour financer des
éoliennes alors je suis contre la
réforme des retraites que ce soit clair
ce serait plutôt pour financer des
sources d'énergie rationnelles et
scientifiques mais simplement un petit
une petite chose sur les comparaisons
européennes vous avez évoqué les âges
légaux en fait les âges les goûts n'ont
pas grand intérêt ce qui compte
effectivement la Suède égale 61 j'étais
pas au courant que là je légale en Suède
était aussi bas en revanche de départ
effectivement et 66 ans je sais envoyer
de certains pays il y a une différence
dans beaucoup de pays bien sûr entre les
femmes et les hommes exactement plus
qu'en France d'ailleurs exactement voilà
ce qui fait que c'est aussi parce que la
France a un taux d'emploi des femmes
plus élevé que dans la plupart pays donc
elles ont elles accumulent plus de droit
à la retraite et elle partent à peu près
au même moment que les hommes
contrairement à d'autres pays où l'écart
est plus important donc
le le
symbole plus qu'autre chose c'est énorme
je rejoins aussi madame tricot sur le
fait que c'est pas parce que l'Allemagne
ne fait qu'on est obligé de le faire on
le fait pour les raisons que j'ai évoqué
c'est-à-dire que on doit redresser nos
finances publiques d'une manière ou
d'une autre alors je conçois qu'il y ait
d'autres façons de redresser les
finances publiques par exemple de
d'augmenter monstrueusement la taxation
de quelques dizaines de milliards
d'euros ça pose aussi quelques problèmes
et ce n'est pas que Monsieur Arnaud à
mon avis qui va être concerné et donc on
peut évidemment augmenter la taxection
mais si on considère c'est une option
parmi d'autres mais il se trouve que
c'est la mienne que on a déjà la
pression fiscale la plus élevée du monde
enfin du monde occidental en tout cas
bossure enfin on est en concurrence avec
la Belgique mais même ils ont besoin
d'autres pays sont tous alors donc si
vous voulez on peut effectivement
plaider pour une augmentation massive
parce qu'il faudrait qu'elle soit
massive de la pression fiscale alors on
peut fantasme en pensant que c'est que
quelques individus qui paient mais bon
c'est peu probable ou alors
effectivement on fait des économies sur
les dépenses et comme je disais tout à
l'heure le seul poste d'économie énorme
de plusieurs dizaines de milliards c'est
évidemment pas sur la santé la défense
la police l'enseignement supérieur etc
c'est évidemment sur sur les retraites
il se trouve que par ailleurs on est en
retard par rapport aux autres pays et
que le problème du carreleur en
Allemagne a pu se traiter il doit
pouvoir se traiter aussi de manière
intelligente pour le carreleur français
Eric de Lana vous l'avez évoqué tout à
l'heure c'est quoi une question de
crédibilité internationale après trois
ans de quoi qu'il en coûte c'est ce que
vous nous dites oui tout à fait il y a
une question de crédibilité
internationale dans un cadre
augmentation des taux je précise bien ça
parce que au final quand on recrute
quand on arrive à acheter de l'argent
sur les marchés à 0 % finalement c'est
totalement indolore et la France est une
est un pays qui est une chaîne sur
valable le problème c'est ne pas faire
comme les autres le problème c'est de
faire la démonstration qu'on a une
capacité réformatrice ce qui est très
différent capacité réformatrice parce
que quand un investisseur met de
l'argent dans les dans la dette d'un
pays il a il a l'espoir qu'un jour il
sera payé en retour et il sera un pays
en retour si les pays finances publiques
ils sont qu'elles sont maîtrisées et si
elle sent que les infrastructures du
pays vont évoluer dans le bon sens ça
veut dire qu'Emmanuel Macron doit
communiquer sur la scène internationale
dans ce sens en disant je fais cette
réforme et donc nos finances publiques
vont s'assainir et vous pourrez venir
investir chez nous normalement ça
devrait la cohérence qui devrait être
effectivement ça donc
énergétique et environnementale vous
savez l'actualité européenne mais c'est
pas le débat vous verriez que le le
gouvernement actuel avec le groupe
Renaissance à la
au cas Parlement européen fait
énormément sur la problématique
énergétique mais c'est un autre sujet
sur la partie du travail je voudrais
revenir sur un sur une thématique là on
a une confrontation en fait de deux
visions de la société moi quand
j'entends pression pressurer ce qui
travaille moi ça me vrille les oreilles
en fait le travail n'est pas là pour
pressurer les gens le travail est là
pour donner dignité aux gens parlez-en
chômeurs les chômeurs veulent retrouver
du travail parce que c'est un vecteur de
lien social pressurer le travail mais
mais mais de quoi on parle on parle
effectivement de quelques métiers
difficiles qui seront pris en compte
dans cette réforme des retraites sur
lequel il y a encore des choses à
regarder mais sur lequel la pénibilité
doit être prise en compte mais le regard
qui est un rapport au travail qui
consisterait à dire que ça a servi
mécaniquement ça fera qu'on n'ira jamais
vers une réforme où on travaille plus
longtemps et ça c'est un vrai problème
par rapport à un regard sur la société
c'est un premier sujet le deuxième sujet
oui mais on sait qu'il y a beaucoup de
de d'entreprises qui ont du mal à
embaucher aujourd'hui pour des raisons
multiples si on peut être liés au
salaire à la perte de sens du justement
du travail donc c'est peut-être aussi
que le travail est pas si
ça ne veut pas dire que énergisant ou
positive que vous le dites
de Français qui aujourd'hui se disent
j'ai après la crise covid finalement je
vais je vais pas j'ai quitter mon
travail et j'hésite à en reprendre un
tout de suite c'est pas c'est pas
totalement neutre quand vous avez tout à
fait raison seulement salarial je
l'avais tout à fait raison je je mettrai
un petit bémol sur le fait quand même
que pour la première fois depuis la
crise covid le taux de satisfaction des
citoyens vis-à-vis des entreprises va
vers la confiance 75% des Français ont
confiance dans l'entreprise comme étant
certainement un dernier lieu où il y a
une sérétine sérénité dans le lien au
travail et dans le lien social donc la
vision d'entreprise elle est pas si
négative que ça dans le dans les dans
l'imaginaire des Français bon simplement
c'est entretenu et c'est bien dommage
parce que finalement quand j'entends la
conférence de presse d'Elisabeth borne
on a affaire la pédagogie ou finalement
il n'y a pas de brut regardez la
brutalité dont on parle dont on entend
partout sur la gauche qui se dit mon
dieu c'est une réforme brutale mais
quelle est la brutalité la clause du
grand-père pour l'origine des retraites
est-ce que c'est de la brutalité alors
il faut expliquer donc c'est à la RATP
ou l'industrie gazière électrique c'est
les nouveaux arrivants qui sont de 40
ans quasiment enfin je veux dire c'est
incroyable le fait que ce qu'on va
appliquer là ça ne s'applique que dans
10 ans dans 10 ans ça s'applique le
premier septembre mais la réforme a
s'appuyé 1er septembre mais ça aura des
conséquences dans le 1er septembre c'est
trois mois de plus pour ceux qui sont
d'accord avec Catherine tricot là en ce
moment tout le monde tout le monde
regarde est-ce que tout le monde calcule
je suis concerné combien de mois
supplémentaires et je vais donner un
point d'accord avec Madame quand même ce
n'est pas vrai sur le fait que c'est que
ça change quelque chose il faut savoir
qu'avec les réformes qui ont déjà eu
lieu notamment la réforme Touraine ou la
réforme de 2010 l'âge effectif de départ
en retraite on en parlait tout à l'heure
en France et déjà supérieur à 63 ans
donc c'est un changera rien en septembre
en fait dans le dans le dans le fait du
départ effectif il se trouve le cadre
mais pour le cas
il part déjà et voilà exactement c'est
bien le problème c'est que les cadres
ils sont arrivés sur le marché de
travail plus tard ni pour ça en revanche
très très tôt qui sont dans les
carrières longues là où je suis d'accord
avec tricot c'est que il est vrai que
les pensions risquent de baisser
pourquoi les pensions risquent de
baisser parce qu'on relève l'âge de la
retraite de manière très faible mais on
augmente le nombre de de d'annuités
enfin de de trimestre pour pouvoir avoir
le taux plein très fort donc il risque
d'y avoir pour une partie de la
population une décote qui sera plus
importante s'il décide de partir plus
tôt que l'âge légal 43 ans pour
atteindre un taux plein des 2027
aux gens à travailler plus alors on va
peut-être on ne paye plus les retraites
sur l'augmentation des salaires mais sur
l'augmentation du coût de la vie
c'est-à-dire qu'on a oui ça fait très
longtemps
et ça s'ajoute je vais reprendre la map
parce qu'on va essayer pendant ce débat
d'écouter d'autres extraits de la
conférence
d'Elizabeth borne je vous en propose un
alors je sais pas si la enragé vous êtes
prêt à me suivre mais c'est celui sur le
justement les les petites retraites ce
qu'a annoncé la première ministre c'est
que ce ce montant de 1200 euros minimum
allez concerner tous les enfin les
retraités actuels et pas seulement les
futurs en écoute Elisabeth borne
une vie de travail doit garantir une
retraite digne
conformément à notre engagement des
salariés et les indépendants notamment
les artisans et les commerçants qui ont
cotisé toute leur vie avec des revenus
autour du SMIC partiront désormais avec
une pension de 85% du SMIC net soit une
augmentation de 100 euros par mois c'est
près de 1200 euros par mois dès cette
année les uns et les autres ont souligné
que les femmes et les indépendants
étaient la majorité de ceux qui touchent
les plus petites retraites
une inégalité majeure à laquelle nous
voulons répondre alors sur ce point là
parce que ça c'est quand même alors
effectivement c'est une demande du parti
let on va y revenir dans un instant sur
les enjeux politiques on va dire de
cette réforme mais c'est quand même un
signal de justice qui est envoyé par le
gouvernement c'est une loi qui existe
depuis 2003 donc ils vont se conformer à
une loi qui a 20 ans qui avait donc on
peut se dire que enfin ça c'est le
premier point le deuxième point c'est
que ça sera pour tous ceux qui ont une
carrière pleine c'est-à-dire que quand
on a travaillé 43 ans dans sa vie gloire
on peut partir avec 1200 euros
c'est-à-dire que quand même il faut se
rendre compte où on en est quoi si on
avait un petit salaire si oui quand avec
au minimum 1200 euros c'est 43 ans de
cotisations vous ouvre à au minimum 1200
euros ce qui quand même
tout le monde en conviendra n'est quand
même pas formidable pour une vie de
labeur entière c'est-à-dire que si vous
n'avez pas les 43 ans vous ne les avez
pas donc bien sûr que c'est bien bien
pas sûr qu'il le fallait et ça fait 20
ans que c'était inscrit dans la loi
alors il y a deux batailles à mener pour
pour l'exécutif pour les habits bornes
et Emmanuel Macron il y a la bataille
politique au Parlement on y reviendra
dans un instant mais d'abord celle de
l'opinion il va falloir convaincre des
Français qui selon les instituts de
sondage sont pour l'instant
majoritairement opposés à cette réforme
je vous propose d'écouter plusieurs
réactions glanées dans l'après-midi
réaction de Français face à cette
réforme des retraites on en a choisi
trois la retraite c'est bien jusqu'à 65
ans mais à partir de 50 ans il est
difficile pour quelqu'un de trouver un
emploi donc que va-t-il faire de 50 à 65
ans pendant 15 ans il va rester
demandeur d'emploi avant de passer dans
une passer à la retraite ça me paraît
loin en tout cas pour moi déjà
voilà je pars plus du principe que aussi
chacun individuellement il faut qu'on
prévoit aussi un petit peu la suite pour
chacun il faut se baser sur nos amis
européens et ils sont tous ils partent
tous pardon à la retraite un peu plus
tard que nous et ce qu'aujourd'hui à 60
ans on est capable de tenir un poste de
travail dignement moi je pense que oui
gagner la bataille de l'opinion Laetitia
pour l'instant c'est plutôt mal parti
vous êtes critique sur la méthode Macron
quoi oui pour moi c'est une
communication qui est complètement à
l'envers c'est un rattache total tout le
monde a été convié à cette grande
concertation à Matignon puis à l'Elysée
on va pas être naïf donc allez dans
l'exécutif il y avait les chefs de
parties les chefs de groupe
parlementaire les syndicats et puis il y
a les grands oubliés finalement de ce
dialogue les Français les premiers
concernés Emmanuel Macron est passé
totalement à côté d'une opportunité
qu'il avait d'illustrer cette nouvelle
méthode vous souvenez quand il a été élu
il nous a parlé d'une nouvelle méthode
de discussion de dialogue entre le haut
et le bas il avait là vraiment
l'occasion en or et il l'a raté donc on
aurait pu avoir quoi un grand débat
façon gilet jaune c'est ça exactement
jaune oui oui il sait que les Français
sont retifs à toute idée de réforme des
retraites c'est un tabou finalement on
parle toujours de ce tabou totem pour
l'âge mais c'est pas ça c'est les
retraites quand les retraites on se
crispe d'ailleurs il nous avait dit
qu'on était des Gaulois réfractaires et
bien toutes les enquêtes d'opinion vous
l'avez dit aussi on va le rappeler avec
le dernier sondage odoxa pour challenge
regardez 83 pour cent des Français se
disent opposés au report de la jegal à
65 ans et seul 16% approuve l'âge donc à
donner à Isabelle borde de 64 ans 26
c'était pas beaucoup hein serait
d'accord avec 63 ans cette enquête
Thomas elle montre surtout la grande
défiance des Français envers le
gouvernement puisque
71% doute que le gouvernement puisse
simplement mener cette réforme et 72%
que cette réforme soit juste socialement
donc oui c'était le moment pour Emmanuel
Macron qui pousse cette réforme depuis
2017 je vous le rappelle de retrousser
ses manches et d'organiser les réunions
publiques comme il sait le faire et en
plus il avait l'outil idéal c'est même
lui qui l'a inventé cet outil le CNR qui
porte symboliquement parce que c'est le
même acronyme l'héritage du Conseil
National de la Résistance alors là il
s'agit pour Emmanuel Macron du Conseil
national de la refondation mais le
Conseil National de la Résistance c'est
lui qui a voté à la sortie de la
deuxième guerre mondiale la première loi
sur l'assurance vieillesse et c'était le
12 septembre 1946 vous pouvez regarder
par exemple sur internet je me suis
amusé cet après-midi à voir ce que le
CNR d'Emmanuel Macron faisait alors il
planche c'est vrai sur beaucoup de
sujets fondamentaux de sociétés comme la
fanb et puis comme le Bien Vieillir je
me suis dit tiens le Bien Vieillir on va
peut-être trouver un petit alinéa sur
les retraites ou un petit paragraphe
rien rien du tout rien sur les retraites
donc Emmanuel Macron je pense à
totalement raté cette grande
concertation nationale se fasse
opposition aussi c'est ça qui est
intéressant mais tout à fait
l'opposition saisie la balle au bon la
balle de l'opinion publique alors je
vais vous laisser écouter Fabien Roussel
du Parti communiste il était invité des
quatre vérités c'était ce matin sur
France 2 nous demandons un grand débat
d'ailleurs le Parti communiste français
est à l'initiative d'une pétition sur
internet une bonne pension une bonne
retraite.fr vous pouvez aller voir avec
des propositions et une pétition
voilà il saisit l'opinion publique
évidemment
la pétition l'appel à manifester
finalement même si le gouvernement
réussi à faire passer ce texte 149-3 en
envoyant directement au Sénat il risque
et on le sait déjà puisqu'il y a des
appels à manifester qui sont qui sont
déposés et puis des appels à la grève
aussi elle a RATP à la SNCF on sait que
la France peut être bloquée merci
Laetitia pour pour cette analyse
Bertrand Martineau vous avez été je le
rappelle conseiller social de Nicolas
Sarkozy à l'Élysée que cherche un
président qui lance une réforme des
retraites quel soutien cherche-t-il
auprès des notamment peut-être des
syndicats des partenaires comment ça se
passe d'abord une recherche pas la
popularité quand il fait une réforme des
retraites mais
ça m'amusé aussi de 83 % des Français
qui sont contre y compris les retraités
parce que quand on regarde les actifs
c'est pire c'est plutôt 90% des actifs
qui sont cons parce que les retraités
qui sont pas concernés sont plus ou
moins pour à 40% je crois voilà mais si
vous regardez les actifs en fait
l'opposition est encore pire vous voyez
voilà donc
la mécanique de l'exécutif elle est très
simple toute façon on parle de débat on
parle de concertation on parle de
pédagogie on parle d'erreur de
communication bon on fait des réformes
des retraites depuis 1993 pas de des
efforts de redressement du système de
retraite bon elle a dur qui est celle
qui a remporté le plus d'ailleurs grâce
à la désinfectation que vous évoquez on
a gagné c'est sans doute à peu près 50
milliards aujourd'hui on aurait 50
milliards de charges de plus excusez du
peu s'il y avait pas eu la réforme
Balladur la seule de 93 donc il n'y a
pas je veux dire il n'y a pas de bonne
communication ça se saurait il y a
toujours un front syndical
il y a pas de bons moments parce que
faut pas faire une réforme pendant une
récession c'est pas mal hein ça veut
dire qu'on touche pas aux retraites non
c'est pas ça non en terme de
communication politique il n'y a pas de
bons moments si Emmanuel Macron nous a
prévu une nouvelle méthode de
concertation là
sauf les Français vous reprenez vous
reprenez tous les gimmicks de
communication depuis des décennies il
faut faire des débats il faut
communiquer il faut faire de la
pédagogie on retrouve toujours 20 et à
chaque fois c'est pareil les gens sont
dans la rue parce qu'on touche quelque
chose qui à mon avis n'est pas qu'un
sujet du rapport au travail c'est
beaucoup plus que ça qui se pose c'est
une question de crise politique beaucoup
plus générale que le sujet des retraites
mais je vous fiche mon billet que si
Emmanuel Macron a changé d'avis et
faisait une déclaration comme quoi
finalement il n'y a pas de problème de
système de retrait des financement du
système de retrait je pense que les gens
hurleraient à la mort en disant ils nous
ment en fait on a un énorme problème de
financement des retraites voilà j'en
suis absolument persuadé
il descend la tête pas dans la rue et le
gouvernement gagnerait même pas en
popularité dans l'autre sens donc toute
façon il y a rien à faire je pense donc
courage politique c'est ce que vous nous
dit alors c'est un mélange de courage
politique et puis c'est aussi une
nécessité c'est à dire qu'en politique
vous faites pas ce que vous voulez il y
a effectivement à terme les contraintes
que vous aviez indiquées c'est les
marchés financiers on en a pas beaucoup
parlé mais parce que aujourd'hui la
question de se pose pas parce
qu'effectivement comme la banque
centrale nous achète notre endettement
effectivement pour l'instant ça pose pas
de problème et les taux d'intérêt
augmentent et même à l'horizon de 2-3
ans la question de la soutenabilité de
la dette et des charges d'intérêt de la
dette je rappelle que les charges
d'intérêt de la dette aujourd'hui c'est
le même budget que l'éducation nationale
c'est un petit sujet quand même bon donc
vous avez effectivement du courage
politique puis vous avez aussi la
nécessité c'est à dire que le fait que
vous ne pouvez pas faire autrement je
rappelle que monsieur tipras qui était
communiste en Grèce il a fait une
réforme des retraites absolument
terrifiante en Grèce bon
j'imagine qu'il l'a pas fait de gaieté
de cœur j'imagine qu'il a pas fait pour
être pression de l'Union européenne
aussi sous pression des marchés parce
que l'Union européenne c'est celle c'est
quand même le contribuable européen qui
l'aidait à boucler ses fins que vous
avez dit il y a jamais de bons moments
de revenir quand même sur cette question
du du timing pardon de cette anglicisme
Eric de c'est vrai qu'on est quand même
dans une dans un contexte qu'un contexte
de succession de crises un contexte de
tension sur le pouvoir d'achat
d'inflation bon il y a ça voilà est-ce
qu'il y a est-ce qu'il y a voilà il y a
toujours des crises c'est ce que vous
dites mais est-ce que c'est le meilleur
moment pour lancer une réforme même sur
l'acceptabilité de par l'opinion c'est
mais déjà de mon point de vue
l'acceptabilité de par l'opinion comment
voulez-vous que quelqu'un à qui on dit
vous allez travailler plus longtemps
vous disent je suis d'accord
c'est-à-dire qu'en gros dans
l'acceptabilité de l'opinion on a
commencé par réduire la réforme des
retraites à un changement d'âge légal de
la retraite c'est pas comme ça qu'il
fallait présenter
alors non mais moi je suis un
nostalgique de la réforme systémique de
2017 il est évident mais on est revenu à
quelque chose qui est qui ressemble une
négociation de boutiquier sur un âge
légal mais la réforme des retrait bien
plus que ça et d'ailleurs Isabelle borne
l'a bien rappelé c'est un peu justice
sociale je dis un peu parce qu'il y a
encore des choses à négocier notamment
sur la pénibilité et c'est et c'est mais
non mais c'est c'est justifié les
carrières longues c'est accompagner les
seniors il faudrait présenter la réforme
des retraites comme ça a été fait
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui de manière
pédagogique pour enfin que les Français
se prononcent sur quelque chose de de de
une vraie image de ce que c'est que la
réforme des retraites moi je pense que
la communication en l'occurrence je suis
assez d'accord sur le fait que il y a
pas de bonne communication mais d'abord
il y avait un risque il y avait un
risque majeur parce que je veux dire
c'est la première chose quand on sait
que l'opinion est d'emblée contre
instrumentaliser un petit peu à juste
titre par l'opposition c'est facile
forcément on va pas aller se prendre des
coups deuxièmement il y avait qu'un même
un sujet de temporalité c'est à dire
qu'en gros il voulait aller vite et
consulter l'opinion si on veut le faire
bien ça prend du temps et enfin il y
avait un sujet qu'il faut pas négliger
et qui a été complètement raté pour le
coup c'était une volonté de relégitimité
les syndicats
il y a une volonté de légitimiser les
syndicats avec une concertation qui a
été exclusivement avec les syndicats
avec tous les syndicats pendant
plusieurs mois il se trouve que ça n'a
pas marché ils en ont fait un totem mais
quand même on peut pas à la fois aller
directement à l'opinion en squisant les
syndicats et vouloir aux légitimiser le
syndicats
ne vient pas dans haut mais d'en bas et
qu'ils ont perdu la légitimité de la
base oui c'est ça mais ça fait longtemps
mais ça pouvait être une bonne manière
par le haut ça pose une vraie question
on va terminer ce chapitre sur la
bataille de l'opinion sur la capacité
des syndicats à tenir un mouvement comme
celui-là on a vu ce qui s'est passé à la
SNCF juste avant Noël avec un mouvement
qui finalement était né quoi sur sur les
réseaux sociaux il faut dire il faut
dire les choses et qui a échappé aux
principaux syndicats de la SNCF donc ça
va être une c'est une vraie question et
je pense que personne ici à la réponse
sur
l'aspect conflictuel de ce de ce
mouvement et de ce qui va naître là dans
les prochains jours dans les prochaines
semaines et donc moi je boucle sur ce
que je disais au départ c'est que si on
veut recoudre le pays le réunifier il
faut pas faire ça il faut avoir des
projets et quand Macron dit mon
quinquennat sera à écologique ou ne sera
pas il fallait faire ça ce n'est pas ce
qu'il fait je regrette mais il ne porte
pas de réforme structurelle il nous
explique que la la mère des batailles
c'est de trouver 13 milliards pour faire
la réforme des retraites quand on sait
quand on sait l'ampleur des
transformations qui peuvent être
excusez-moi messieurs si je peux juste
vous dire une chose c'est que depuis
1993 donc elle a dure et tous ceux qui
ont suivi on peut pas dire qu'on est le
sentiment d'être dans un pays fringant
qui va vachement bien et qui est
confiant dans son avenir peut-être qu'il
faut juste
qu'il faut peut-être un tout petit peu
faire confiance aux Français et remettre
les choses c'est pas parce qu'ils sont
contre qu'ils ont tort si les Français
sont contre ils ont peut-être de bonnes
d'être opposé à cette réforme alors on
va écouter un autre extrait de la
conférence de presse d'Elizabeth Borre
nous là elle rappelle elle fait un peu
de politique aussi elle rappelle tout
simplement que cette réforme des
retraites c'était une promesse du
candidat Emmanuel Macron lors de sa
campagne pour ça réélection en écoute la
première ministre la nécessité d'adapter
notre système pour le préserver a été au
cœur de la campagne présidentielle puis
de celle des législatives ça n'est donc
une surprise pour personne
notre ambition a été portée en toute
transparence par le Président de la
République et partager avec les Français
voilà et ça ouvre évidemment le dernier
chapitre de ce débat sur la bataille
politique au Parlement je propose à
Quentin calmé de nous rejoindre sur ce
plateau bonsoir Quentin venu à vous on
s'y attendait sans surprise cette
réforme elle est saluée par la droite
sénatoriale oui c'est vrai que ça
faisait plusieurs jours qu'il y avait
une rumeur comme ça qui montait on
comprenait que le gouvernement avait
choisi de proposer une version de la
réforme des retraites qui colle à ce que
propose les LR au Sénat depuis 2019
alors écoutez Bruno Retailleau nous
sommes allés à la réunion de groupe DLR
ce matin au Sénat et avant même les
annonces il ne cachait pas à sa
satisfaction écoutez le chef de fil DLR
au Sénat les annonces du gouvernement
pourrait être si ça se confirme la
victoire du projet de réforme des
retraites du Sénat puisque la première
ministre va vraisemblablement annoncer
dans quelques heures une réforme qui
utilise les deux leviers c'est le même
que nous votions d'habitude le levier du
report de l'âge légal à 64 ans et 65 ans
et l'autre levier de la durée de
cotisation de l'accélération de la
réforme dite Touraine voilà avant même
les annonces un dessinateur qui
applaudissait ce matin mais alors il
fixait deux lignes rouges trois
informations oui c'est ça ils avaient
compris ce qu'elle est ce jouet
effectivement plus tard dans la journée
mais donc de l'ignorer rouge la
revalorisation des petits retraites et
le rapprochement des régimes spéciaux au
régime général là encore ils ont eu un
causes oui effectivement donc satisfaits
de la droite sénatoriale mais c'est
plutôt à l'assemblée que le gouvernement
compte sur les voies DLR oui bien sûr
les républicains détiennent avec leur 62
voix à l'Assemblée nationale la clé de
la majorité absolue pour et bien ne pas
avoir un recours aux 49-3 cet après-midi
le chef de fil des députés LR est revenu
sur la question des petites retraites
importées à 85% du SMIC la première
ministre lui a répondu c'était la séance
des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement c'est donc là encore avant
les annonces écouter un extrait de
l'échange
par dessus tout il faut réparer une
injustice c'est 2 millions de retraités
qui ont cotisé toute leur vie ont
travaillé dur ont des carrières
complètes souvent des femmes des
commerçants des artisans qui perçoivent
aujourd'hui des retraites indignes
autour de 900 euros par mois c'est un
digne d'un grand pays comme le nôtre
êtes-vous prête madame la Première
ministre à leur garantir à eux aussi une
retraite minimum de 1200 euros et pas
seulement au futur retraités je vous le
dis très clairement c'est pour nous une
condition impérative merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président de marlex nous
avons également échangé ces derniers
jours sur la situation des retraités qui
après toute une vie de travail avec un
revenu modeste touche aujourd'hui de
très petites pensions je vous confirme
monsieur le Président que j'ai bien
entendu la demande de votre groupe nous
partageons cette préoccupation une
carrière complète doit permettre d'avoir
une pension digne j'aurai l'occasion d'y
revenir tout à l'heure mais nous prêt à
y travailler je vous remercie
la première ministre qui la confirmé ça
concernera donc au total 2 millions de
petites retraites un dernier mot sur un
camp qui reste chez les LR autour de
d'Aurélien Pradier le camp le plus
critique de la réforme ils ne veulent
l'oeil il ne voulait pas a priori des
mesures d'âge et ce matin en réunion de
groupe à l'Assemblée nationale le député
Raphaël berger proche d'Aurélien Pradier
a déclaré on le construit pas une
réforme structurelle et fondamentale
sous les ordres de la République entre
Noël et l'épiphanie un petit pic comme
ça à l'endroit d'ericsiotti puisqu'il y
a donc eu se ralliement de la position
des LR ces dernières semaines ces
derniers jours merci beaucoup Quentin
calmé Bertrand Martineau est-ce que
finalement
l'architecture de cette réforme n'est
pas plus dictée par des considérations
politiques voilà faire plaisir aux
parties LR et obtenir leur soutien à
l'assemblée que par une analyse vraiment
économique non mais les détails oui
enfin les 85% du SMIC qui s'appelle au
stock de retraités n'est pas un détail à
mon avis sans le même sans les LR je
pense que le gouvernement leur aurait
fait aussi parce que ça va être bien vu
dans l'opinion publique et puis en
particulier par les retraités qui vont
globalement soutenir la réforme
probablement même si c'est pas eux qui
descendent le plus dans la rue donc je
pense que c'est pas dicté principalement
par des considérations très très
politiques sauf les curseurs il y a pas
beaucoup de levier vous avez le levier
de la durée de cotisation il a déjà été
très très largement eu utilisé parce que
43 années de cotisation c'est quand même
beaucoup dans sur un marché du travail
où les gens maintenant souvent ne
rentrent pas avant 23 24 ans surtout à
l'horizon 2050 il y aura quand même
beaucoup de ça veut dire que c'est des
gens qui n'auront pas leur retraite à
taux plein avant 68 ans mais donc on
peut pas aller beaucoup plus loin sur la
durée de cotisation
on n'a pas envie de baisser les
retraites il y avait l'option évidemment
d'une taxation un peu généralisée avec
des milliards et des milliards ou de
faire financer par la planète Mars ou
par les éoliennes j'en sais rien mais ça
ça a été c'est pas très crédible et puis
évidemment il y avait le levier de l'âge
légal qui est effectivement le plus
j'allais dire le plus brutal le plus
basique on va dire et qui rapporte le
plus d'argent à court terme donc voilà
donc c'est plutôt un sujet technique là
peut être aussi le plus simplement
compréhensible de tous
on essaye de mettre un peu de complexité
évidemment dans ce débat mais c'est
peut-être aussi une des raisons pour
lesquelles Emmanuel Macron finalement
est venu à une mesure d'âge
dans ce débat la question de l'âge
minimum c'est pas complexe tout le monde
peut comprendre et ça selon un endroit
où est-ce que je dis ouais j'ai
peut-être pas bien exprimé mais c'est ce
que je voulais dire des éléments de
simplicité dans cette affaire il y a
alors le système globalement très
complexe
Eric Delannoy est-ce que le cette
réforme là celle qui est qui qui démarre
finalement aujourd'hui avec cette
conférence de presse en fin d'après-midi
de la première Miss est-ce que son
logiciel est daté pour vous est-ce que
c'est une vieille réforme vous voyez ce
que je veux dire ah bah il est daté dans
la manière de faire évidemment parce que
je veux dire quelle est la différence
entre ce qu'on est en train de vivre là
et ce que l'on vit depuis 1993 avec
quelques d'ailleurs certains premiers
ministres qui en ont souffert beaucoup
donc elle est datée et du coup les
réactions sont les mêmes
enfin ça toujours été mais toujours les
mêmes arguments pour dire qu'il ne faut
pas faire ça a toujours été on va dans
la rue et on va bloquer le pays parce
qu'il faut pas faire mais si on n'avait
pas fait les différentes réformes 93 95
enfin pas eu en 95 de 2010 de 2014 etc
en fait on serait vraiment dans le rouge
en fait est-ce que là le pays peut
bloquer justement en descendant dans la
rue cette région
historique qui est qu'à chaque fois à
chaque fois qu'on a eu l'Assemblée
nationale un vote qui a été fait la
mobilisation s'effacer bon c'est pour ça
que Emmanuel Macron cherche l'accord
avec les lèvres ça j'ai bien compris
mais il y a cette nouvelle dimension de
de mouvement un peu hors syndicat qui
qui complique l'équation vous aurez le
dernier mot tiens Catherine tricot de ce
de ce débat sur l'analyse politique
c'est aussi un cadeau
à la Nupe et aux forces parfois un peu
disparaître de la nuque cette réforme ah
bah si cette réforme de retraite bah oui
c'est c'est un ciment c'est un ciment
tout trouvé quand même
je trouve que c'est pas si simple que ça
puisque à l'intérieur de la nuque il y a
quand même quelques petites nuances je
veux dire la réforme Touraine qui est
quand même la réforme Touraine qui est
quand même si tu es en exemple dans
cette enfin qui est appelé à la
rescousse ça fait pas forcément les
heureux partout bon donc je pense que
c'est pas si évident que ça et je ne
crois pas du tout qu'il ait voulu faire
un cadeau à la nuque je pense qu'il a
cherché
de fait c'est un ça permet aux
particuliers qui qui composent la nuque
de d'afficher voilà j'espère que ce que
j'espère c'est que ça va permettre à la
gauche dans son ensemble c'est-à-dire
pas simplement la gauche politique et
institutionnelle qui est à l'Assemblée
mais à la gauche sociale à la gauche
syndicale etc de se rassembler j'espère
qu'elle va gagner qu'elle va se faire
entendre on verra ça dans les prochaines
semaines parce que évidemment il y aura
d'autres débats sur cette réforme des
retraites il y a plein de thèmes dont on
n'a pas parlé ça tombe bien parce que ça
va donner des éléments par exemple
l'emploi des seniors on l'a pas évoqué
très important évidemment il y a la
question du tabou de la capitalisation
tiens on aurait pu aussi parler de ça
donc il y aura d'autres débats sur ce
thème dans ce sens public évidemment on
vous le promet merci à tous les 30 en
tout cas d'avoir participé à ce
lancement de la réforme des retraites